What do you think about sourdough bread in ration?
So this one came from a patient who asked great about this question.
So I thought this would be a good question to pull the zoom call.
So sourdough bread is the biggest thing on the internet right now.
Maybe it depends on who you're following, but it's definitely a homestead
big thing. A lot of people are making their own sourdough bread
and sourdough bread has a lot of advantages over regular bread.
And I'm a big fan of sourdough bread over regular bread.
It tastes better, it's better for you.
But again, there's some negatives. So negative number one is sourdough bread does not
not contain gluten. So if you are staying away from gluten, it still has gluten.
Now it is true. You'll see a lot of testimonials out there of people that
have issues with gluten, not celiac disease, but gluten-sensitivity issues
that say that they could eat sourdough bread when they couldn't eat other bread.
It is true. It has a less of a gluten load.
But the sourdough bread that you make, you also have to look at the flour that you're using
to make the sourdough bread. If it's a natural iron corn or a natural
type flour, that is a more of an ancient grain. That's going to be much better,
but it's still going to have gluten. So if a person does have gluten-sensitivity,
if we've done the Cyrex array, three array, four array, ten, and we've determined that you do have
antibodies to glean in its peptides, then you can't have sourdough bread unless it's made from
a true gluten-free flour. If you, we have not done those tests, and if you, if you're
how it would be, I don't think I have gluten-sensitivity, that's not my issue.
But you just put limit gluten on my food restrictions for cancer.
Can I still have sourdough bread just once in a while? Well, if you're just limiting gluten
because I said that it came up as a partial driver for your cancer, that eating piece of sourdough bread
once a week would probably be just fine. I would still try to get it sourced
in a natural possible, because a lot of people are making sourdough bread from kills very flour
or something. So if you're getting it from a natural ancient grade, and you don't have a gluten-sensitivity,
and I solely put limit gluten on your dietary restriction, and then I would say in ration,
if your definition of in ration is having it once a week, and I'd say you're fine with that.
But if you have a gluten-sensitivity, and if I said no gluten, absolutely no gluten on your
dietary restriction, then you have to get it from a gluten-free bread flour source.
Hope that answers that up to you.